Hallo, Freunde der Sonne,
ich bin's wieder, Mai,
eure Chemikerin des Vertrauens.
Eigentlich dachte ich, endlich
mal wieder ein klassisches,
naturwissenschaftliches Thema,
mehr Chemie,
nicht so ein politisch-emotional
aufgeladenes Thema wie Corona.
Aber ... Videos über Vitamin D
haben teilweise Kommentarspalten
wie "Impfvideos" ...
Mir war vor der Recherche nicht klar,
was für ein kontroverses Thema
Vitamin D ... also, wie kontrovers
kann ein Vitamin ...
(Seufzen)
Wir brauchen alle Tee. Das ist
heute ausnahmsweise mal Kaffee.
Vielleicht ist das das Problem.
Also, wenn man sich im Netz
über Vitamin D informiert,
scheint es auf den ersten Blick so,
als seien Vitamin D-Supplements,
also, Vitamin D-Tabletten oder
-Tropfen, vor allem hochdosiert,
so das klassischer "Allheilmittel".
Also, klassischer Bullshit,
weil es zwei Red Flags,
also, zwei Warnzeichen
für Bullshit erfüllt.
Erste Red Flag: Ein einziger Stoff
soll die Heilung und Lösung
für eine ganze Bandbreite von
Beschwerden und Krankheiten sein.
"Sie können jede Krankheit nehmen,
die Sie wollen,
alles ist Vitamin D-abhängig."
"Knochengesundheit,
für kardiovaskuläre Erkrankungen,
Autoimmunerkrankungen,
Typ-2-Diabetes, Infekten,
und natürlich
in der Krebsprävention."
"Ja, der Wert mit der höchsten
diagnostischen Kraft
für das Überleben oder die
Sterblichkeit des Menschen
ist tatsächlich Vitamin D."
Zweite Red Flag:
Es ist ein Geheimtipp.
Denn obwohl dieser Stoff so wirksam
ist, oder vielleicht gerade, weil ...
wird er uns vorenthalten.
"In den Medien wird Vitamin D
leider immer wieder verunglimpft,
es wird schlechtgemacht
und es heißt teilweise sogar,
Vitamin D sei gefährlich."
"Nix da. Nur keine Unruhe schaffen."
"Denn wenn man das
in die Bildzeitung geben würde -
alle Kinder haben
einen Vitamin D-Mangel -
müsste man ja was tun."
Klingt, je nach Quelle, nach einer
mehr oder weniger großen Verschwörung
von Ärzten, Pharmaindustrie, Medien,
die ein Mittel zurückhalten wollen,
das ...
äh ... jeder rezeptfrei
überall kaufen kann?
Wie gesagt, das Bullshit-O-Meter
ist eigentlich schon am Anschlag.
Aber: Red Flags sind ja keine Belege.
Sondern erst mal nur ein Grund dafür,
genauer und kritisch hinzuschauen.
Und wenn man das tut,
sieht man,
dass Vitamin D nicht so ist
wie viele andere "Allheilmittel".
Denn seine biochemische Wirkungsweise
ist durchaus plausibel.
Und es gibt seriöse
wissenschaftliche Studien.
Und das schauen wir uns heute mal an.
Deswegen: Holt euch einen Tee, macht
es euch gemütlich, wir steigen durch.
Ers mal:
Unter Vitamin D versteh man
eigentlich eine Gruppe von Vitaminen,
das Bekannteste oder das für uns
Wichtigste ist das Vitamin D3.
Vitamin D hat viele verschiedene
Funktionen im Körper.
Das zeigt sich unter anderem daran:
verschiedene Zelltypen und Organe
tragen Vitamin D-Rezeptoren.
Besonders wichtig ist Vitamin D
für unsere Knochengesundheit.
Vitamin D-Mangel
kann zu Knochenproblemen führen, wie:
Zu viel Vitamin D kann allerdings zu
einer Vitamin D-Vergiftung führen.
Denn es ist ja nicht
wie bei Vitamin C,
da wird alles, was zu viel ist,
einfach wieder rausgepinkelt.
Vitamin D ist allerdings
schlecht wasserlöslich
und damit auch schlecht pinkelbar.
Darum kann es zur Überdosis kommen
und so zu überhöhten Kalziumwerten.
"Hyperkalzämie" nennt sich das,
und geht von milden Symptomen
wie übermäßiges Pipimachen bis zu
schweren Symptomen wie Herzproblemen.
Vitamin D-Vergiftungen
sind aber eher selten.
Weil sie eigentlich
nur durch exzessives Einnehmen
hochdosierter Vitamin D-Präparate
entstehen können.
Die Vitamin D-Hauptquelle
ist die Sonne.
Der Körper stellt Vitamin D
mithilfe von UV-Licht her,
dabei passiert eine sogenannte
"Umlagerung".
Umlagerungen sind ziemlich cool,
weil hier Moleküle
quasi chemische Reaktionen
mit sich selbst eingehen.
Eine Art Transformer-Reaktion.
Und sehr fotogen.
Exzessives Sonnen ist keine Gefahr
für eine Vitamin D-Überdosierung.
Nur für Hautkrebs.
Denn bei natürlichem Sonnenlicht
und entsprechender Wärmeaktivierung
ist die Haut dazu in der Lage,
die Vitamin D-Herstellung
auch wieder runterzuregulieren.
Auch über die Nahrung
nimmt man zwar Vitamin D auf,
zum Beispiel durch Fisch, aber das
macht nur einen kleinen Teil aus.
solange man nicht gerade
Lebertran-Junkie ist.
Da Vitamin D also in erster Linie
ein Freund der Sonne ist,
haben wir im Winter weniger Vitamin D
als im Sommer.
Schauen wir mal in die Daten
einer schwedischen Studie.
Übers Jahr verteilt,
hier sehen wir die zwölf Monate,
sieht es so aus mit der UV-Strahlung.
Im Sommer viel, im Winter wenig.
Hier seht ihr den Vitamin D-Spiegel
von über 600 Erwachsenen,
der jeden Monat über ein Vitamin D-
Abbauprodukt im Blut bestimmt wurde.
Diese Darstellungsart ist übrigens
ein sogenannter Box-Plot.
Diese Antennen hier
erstrecken sich in diesem Fall
vom kleinsten zum größten
gemessenen Wert.
Darunter sind auch starke Ausreißer,
die man entsprechend vorsichtig
bewerten muss, deswegen
gibt es noch diese Boxen.
Die stellen die mittleren 50 Prozent
der Daten dar.
Und die Querstriche
geben den Median an.
Der Median ist der Mittelwert,
allerdings nicht im typischen Sinne
von "Durchschnittswert",
sondern der Wert, der die Daten
in zwei gleich große Hälften teilt.
Man sieht, der Vitamin D-Spiegel
folgt der Sonnenbestrahlung
mit ein bisschen Verzögerung nach.
Bei dieser Studie mit 415 Deutschen -
hier wurden allerdings Ältere,
also 50- bis 80-Jährige, untersucht -
sah der Vitamin D-Jahresverlauf
ähnlich aus.
Vitamin D ist also saisonal.
Genauso saisonal wie die Debatten
um Vitamin D,
denn jeden Winter wird erneut
intensiver darüber diskutiert,
ob man denn jetzt Vitamin D-Supple-
ments zu sich nehmen soll oder nicht.
Das ist die eine spannende Frage.
Nur, dahinter steckt ja noch mehr:
die Saisonalitätshypothese.
Nicht nur Vitamin D ist saisonal,
sondern auch verschiedene
Gesundheitsaspekte.
Das fängt mit Infektionen an.
Also, im Winter ist Erkältungssaison,
im Winter ist Grippesaison,
und momentan sieht es ja so aus,
als sei das neue Coronavirus
auch stark saisonal.
Auch für die psychische Gesundheit
kann die Wintersaison belastend sein.
Vielleicht habt ihr schon
von einer Winterdepression gehört.
Und sogar die allgemeine Todesrate
ist im Winter höher.
In Deutschland sterben etwa
elf Prozent mehr Menschen
in den Wintermonaten als im Sommer.
Da stellt sich die Frage:
Welche Rolle spielt hier Vitamin D?
Natürlich kann man
erst mal ausschließen,
dass hinter all dem einzig und allein
Vitamin D steckt.
Bei Infektionen zum Beispiel wissen
wir, es kommt Verschiedenes zusammen.
Umhüllte Viren, wie etwa Coronaviren,
sind im Winter stabiler.
Dann ist im Winter die
Luftfeuchtigkeit deutlich niedriger,
weswegen Aerosole länger
in der Luft stehen bleiben können.
Und wir verbringen mehr Zeit
zusammen in geschlossenen Räumen,
weswegen wir uns eher
anstecken können.
Das alles gilt auch
für das neue Corona-Virus.
Aber ... könnte Vitamin D nicht
ein zusätzlicher Faktor sein?
In diesem Review gehen die Autoren
speziell weit mit ihrer Einschätzung:
Maßnahmen, die sicherstellen würden,
dass Menschen über das ganze Jahr
eine Vitamin D-Konzentration
von mehr als 36 Nanogramm
pro Milliliter aufweisen,
würden die Todesraten vermutlich
signifikant reduzieren.
Nur müssen wir hier sehr genau auf
Korrelation und Kausalität schauen.
Letztendlich korreliert ja Vitamin D
mit allem, was saisonal ist.
Also, der Vitamin D-Spiegel
korreliert auch ...
negativ mit Lebkuchenkonsum
oder positiv mit Eiskonsum.
Das heißt, allein die Saisonalität
einer Krankheit reicht noch nicht aus
für eine plausible Hypothese.
Beim Infektionsrisiko allerdings
gibt's was Interessantes.
Vitamin D spielt nämlich eine Rolle
im Immunsystem.
Das Immunsystem ist, wohlgemerkt,
ein verdammt komplexes System,
bei dem verdammt viele Stoffe, Zellen
und Prozesse eine Rolle spielen.
Aber wenn man mit einer
täglichen Vitamin D-Tablette
seinem Immunsystem auch nur
ein bisschen helfen könnte,
würd sich das für viele schon lohnen.
Nur, plausibel alleine reicht nicht,
wir müssen das auch noch belegen.
Wie? Mit klinischen Studien.
Okay. Um aus "plausibel"
"belegt" zu machen,
lautet das Zauberwort: doppelblinde,
randomisierte, kontrollierte Studie.
Also, vier Zauberwörter.
Wisst Bescheid:
Testgruppe, Kontrollgruppe,
randomisiert,
also zufällig ausgewählt.
Testgruppe kriegt Vitamin D,
Kontrollgruppe kriegt Placebo
und es ist doppelblind,
das heißt, weder die Teilnehmer
noch die Wissenschaftler wissen, wer
das echte Zeug, wer ein Placebo hat.
Nach solchen Studien
haben wir eben geschaut.
Vor allem auch nach Meta-Analysen.
Die nehmen mehrere klinische Studien
und werten die gesammelt aus.
Es gibt zu dem Thema
so viel Forschung,
dass es inzwischen sogar eine Meta-
analyse über Metaanalysen dazu gibt.
Inception! Und tatsächlich
gibt es Studien, die zeigten,
dass Vitamin D-Supplements vor
Erkältungen, Infektionen schützten.
Allerdings eher bei Probanden, die
deutlichen Vitamin D-Mangel hatten
oder vorerkrankt waren.
Bei normalen, gesunden Menschen
ohne Mangel gibt es für Benefits
durch zusätzliche Vitamin D-Zufuhr
... keine ausreichenden Hinweise.
Und nur, weil Vitamin D jedenfalls
eine Rolle spielt im Immunsystem,
heißt das nicht automatisch,
dass besonders viel Vitamin D
dafür nötig ist.
Also, vielleicht
reicht auch einfach das,
was die meisten eh schon haben.
So ähnlich, wie man Benzin braucht,
um Auto zu fahren,
aber mehr Benzin das Auto
auch nicht schneller macht.
Alles, was darüber hinausgeht, sei es
Diabetes - was wird noch untersucht?
Herz-Kreislauf, Krebs, Depressionen -
das ist alles nicht sehr überzeugend.
Also, man findet nicht nichts, aber
das, was man findet, ist so ... hm.
Als Beispiel: Bei den 25 meistzitier-
ten Studien der letzten vier Jahre
zeigten 20 Studien keinen relevanten
Effekt von Vitamin D-Supplements.
Fünf Studien schon. Allerdings
haben die Sondergruppen untersucht.
Wie Neugeborene
oder Patienten mit Prädiabetes
oder in Methadontherapie.
Unterm Strich muss man sagen:
Vitamin-D-Mangel ist schlecht.
Aber wer keinen Mangel hat,
braucht wahrscheinlich nix extra.
Das Bundesamt für Verbraucherschutz
und Lebensmittelsicherheit
gibt uns folgende Richtwerte:
20 Nanogramm pro Milliliter Blut
wären wünschenswert.
Unter zwölf Nanogramm
und über 50 Nanogramm pro Milliliter
wird's jeweils kritisch.
Wer langfristig solche Werte hat,
hat erhöhtes Risiko für Mangel
beziehungsweise Überschuss.
Und ab 160 Nanogramm pro Milliliter
wird's richtig unangenehm.
Hyperkalzämie lässt grüßen.
Wobei solche Werte immer
mit einer gewissen Unsicherheit
versehen sind.
Diese Werte
sind nicht in Stein gemeißelt,
es geht hier nicht um exakte,
pauschal gültige Werte,
sondern eher um Größenordnungen
zur Orientierung.
Jetzt gibt's aber zwei Ergänzungen -
erstens:
Auch bei kleineren Erhöhungen,
also ab 30 Nanogramm pro Milliliter,
zeigte sich eine Korrelation
mit erhöhtem Risiko
für manche Krebsarten
und Sterblichkeit allgemein.
Aber Achtung: Auch hier sind es
erst mal nur Korrelationen.
Es ist nicht klar,
ob Vitamin D damit
wirklich kausal zusammenhängt,
und selbst wenn,
wie groß sein Beitrag ist.
Zweitens: Auch Werte zwischen zwölf
und 20 Nanogramm pro Milliliter
gelten bereits als suboptimal.
"Suboptimal" heißt hier,
dass man akut
erst mal nichts befürchten muss,
also keine Mangelsymptome
oder Ähnliches,
aber wenn man langfristig
Knochenbeschwerden vorbeugen möchte,
sollte man sich eher
an den 20 Nanogramm pro Milliliter
orientieren.
In genau diesem Bereich -
noch kein Mangel, aber suboptimal -
liegen etwa 60 Prozent der Deutschen.
Und bei etwa 15 Prozent
der Bevölkerung
liegt ein deutlicher
Vitamin-D-Mangel vor.
Die Wirklichkeit
liegt hier also zwischen
"Vitamin-D-Mangel ist ein Mythos"
und "Wir haben alle
Vitamin-D-Mangel".
Die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
hat keinen Vitamin-D-Mangel,
doch mehr als die Hälfte
könnte durch einen höheren
Vitamin-D-Spiegel
langfristig mehr
für ihre Knochengesundheit tun.
Wer allerdings
tatsächliches Mangelrisiko hat,
sind Menschen bestimmter
Risikogruppen, und zwar:
Menschen, die nicht
oder nur wenig rauskommen,
Menschen, die nur
vollständig bedeckt rausgehen,
dunkelhäutige Menschen,
ältere Menschen und Säuglinge.
Doch in jeden Fall
solltet ihr erst zum Arzt gehen,
bevor ihr euch mit Vitamin-D-
Supplements selbst behandelt.
Damit ihr das
auch selbst einschätzen könnt:
Bei Vitamin-D-Präparaten
wird die Vitaminmenge
meist in "Internationalen Einheiten"
angegeben,
"I.E." oder auch "I.U." -
für "international units".
Empfohlen wird
eine Vitamin-D-Zufuhr
von 800 I.E. pro Tag.
Bei fehlender endogener Synthese,
also wenn die Herstellung
durch Sonnenlicht nicht möglich ist.
Sicher gilt eine maximale Zufuhr
von 4.000 I.E. pro Tag.
Wenn ich mir anschaue,
in welchen Dosen
Vitamin-D-Tabletten verkauft werden,
gibt es nur wenige,
bei denen eine Tablette
4.000 I.E. übersteigt.
Wobei man natürlich aufpassen muss:
Alles, was man selbst
mithilfe von Sonnenlicht herstellt,
kommt ja noch oben drauf.
Weswegen man keine pauschalen
Empfehlungen geben sollte.
Diese Video hat
über drei Millionen Aufrufe
und ist ein anderthalbstündige
pauschales "Nehmt alle Vitamin D".
Abgesehen von einigen
wissenschaftlichen Ungenauigkeiten
bis Ungereimtheiten
kann man zumindest sagen:
Gemäßigtes Supplementieren
wird für viele
wenigstens nicht gefährlich sein.
Aber wenn so eine Expertenstimme -
der Mann ist ja Professor,
dem vertrauen dann viele -
so einseitige
und pauschale Claims macht
wie "Vitamin D ist immer super
und kann nie schaden" ...
Dass so was dann
auch Leute motiviert,
die dann völlig eskalieren.
Hier wird bei 70 Kilogramm
Körpergewicht
eine Dosis empfohlen von ...
Hilfe!
Gott sei Dank -
wenigstens nur für zehn Tage im Jahr.
Aber ... ob das gutgeht?
Zumal man hier
für den Rest des Jahres
5.000 I.E. täglich einnehmen soll.
Das sind 25 Prozent über dem
empfohlenen täglichen Maximalwert.
Man sollte zumindest skeptisch sein,
wenn die Person,
die solche Therapien empfiehlt,
Geld mit dem Verkauf
der Supplements verdient.
Und bevor jemand kommt und sagt:
"Quatsch, ich mach das seit Jahren,
mir geht's prächtig!"
Das kann ja sein.
Beziehungsweise,
das kann man ja nur hoffen.
Aber du bist keine Studie.
Du bist ein Mensch.
Und nur weil etwas
für dich vielleicht noch aufgeht,
heißt das nicht, dass andere das
ohne Konsequenzen nachmachen können.
Wir sehen an diesem Messbereich,
wie groß die Schwankungen
zwischen Individuen sind.
Wenn jemand anderen erklärt,
wie viel Vitamin D sie brauchen,
ohne deren Serumwerte
oder deren Lebensstil zu kennen,
dann ist das genau so,
als würd ich ...
euch erklären,
wann ihr euer Auto tanken müsst.
Die Medien reden das klein,
aber in Deutschland
herrscht Benzinmangel!
Willst du riskieren,
dass dein Auto steht?
Ich würde immer
noch 15 Liter draufpacken.
Und zufälligerweise
gibt es nur heute
20 Prozent
in meinem Benzin-Onlineshop!
Wissenschaft
beinhaltet immer Unsicherheiten,
es ist oft frustrierend,
dass es nicht so die einfache,
pauschale Antwort gibt,
die man sich
für seine Gesundheit erhofft hat.
Aber ein paar Dinge -
ausgewogen ernähren ...
ausgewogen bewegen,
also, ja, Sport machen,
aber halt auch nicht übertreiben,
und auf seine
psychische Gesundheit achten -,
das sind Dinge,
die ganz unumstritten
mit allgemeiner Gesundheit
einhergehen.
Deswegen wird euch auch
jede Ärztin und jeder Arzt
zu Sport
und ausgewogener Ernährung raten.
Was sie nicht tun würden,
wenn sie ernsthaft denken würden:
"Je kranker die Leute,
desto reicher werde ich."
Wenn Ärzte
euch zu Vitamin D beraten,
werden die das auch
im Interesse eurer Gesundheit tun.
Deswegen habt auf dem Schirm,
ob ihr vielleicht
zu einer dieser Risikogruppen gehört.
Wenn ja oder
wenn ihr euch nicht sicher seid,
sucht eine Ärztin oder einen Arzt auf
und lasst euch beraten,
bevor ihr
Vitamin-D-Präparate zu euch nehmt.
In der End Card verlinke ich euch
ein nagelneues Scienceformat
beziehungsweise Informatikformat.
Hier erklären euch Anne und Sarina,
was hinter
Netflix-Algorithmen steckt.
Herzlich willkommen bei Funk,
ihr Lieben.
Ich find's richtig cool,
was ihr macht.
Viele Freunde der Sonne
werden auch eure Freunde werden.
Schaut vorbei,
hinterlasst Kekse und Abos.
Hier kommt ihr noch
zu unserem Vitamin-C-Video.
Wir sehen uns, bleibt gesund,
haltet eure Mitmenschen gesund,
und bleibt sicher.